[Inaudible] Oh my God. I know a lot of songs,
but don't ask me singing, you know? Yeah. Well, I'm sorry, mom.
I love you so much. And I, um, in a heartbeat, no, no,
I'm just in general. I just feel sorry for what we're going through,
but every whole family going through the same thing. Right?
I don't think I'm processing it right though. No,
you are a little bit late and I mean, you are going slow.
Like a Steven.
I will look in eyes and then we started crying.
Even now we starting looking eyes and if I like watery
eyes, he started crying, but he never, so his emotions, you know,
don't bottle it up. You gotta get it out. I, I honestly,
I don't know what's going on. I, uh, I think about it every night. I think I,
and I, I sit, I'll sit down at the edge of the bed and analyze like, what,
what am I feeling? What is, why am I? And I just don't know.
I've never been here before. I don't know how to feel.
I don't know how to that's my first husband. I lost.
So how do I fear? I didn't know. That's why, you know,
right after his death,
I was the cry because I didn't expect it that, you know, I thought I,
he, I realized he never gonna come back to me.
You know? That's how we go through it together. Yeah.
It's been hard. Yeah. Well, I mean, we had the up and downs, you know,
one time I hate him. I'm going to divorce him after his kids are growing up,
you know, but then you guys growing up. Wow.
He treated me so nicely.
So I just didn't divorce him and we'll live up to here, you know? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I think that, um, when we, the kids moved out of the house,
it got better for my mom because he relaxed more pressure.
The pressure. Yeah. Or I do, you know, all the education I did.
He didn't do nothing. He just making money. Yeah.
But everything has to my even moving, I have to pack everything,
even little items. He just come in a new house.
They had low, you know, that's what I did for them. That's what she's doing now.
[inaudible] yeah. Get it done, babe. Get it done.
Cause I, my tolerance went away.
Yeah. Every time I get to my job and raising kids today,
that's my eyes up. Could in the house. That's my job. No,
I hired the cleaning lady, but then,
but I got to watch her to do it, you know? Uh,
and he never even [inaudible], you know,
critical activities because I follow them, you know, like, uh,
tennis Kennison and soccer's and soap the boar
and even wrestling. We never played softball.
We never played softball mom one day and,
and Oh yeah. That's a big thing.
I love you. That was weird. You guys bonded as a nice,
because I look like him. I watched his movie like 10 years ago.
Yeah. Yeah.
I wonder if I want to say this mom that I guarantee you,
that, that guy
just saying that guy is this guy maybe
twice or twice as, also in the future. I think he's only,
are you in your twenties? 30. 30? Yeah.
Maybe we might have to show him my mom, the video.
[inaudible] I just want to show her what she'll be.
She'll be disappointed in me. I wasn't scared. I wasn't scared to be really fat.
This used to be really fast.
There's a video of him saying yeah,
by looking at it when you wait, it's a lot heavier,
um, uh, uh, having a once a day. Yeah. Yeah.
So I have a lot intermittent fasting. Wow. Your body's kind of squarish now.
It's weird. Good or bad. It's like SpongeBob, like yellow flourish.
That's good. I know.
I know. That's what I thought.
Curves curve. I know.